Coronavirus has sent a shiver down the spine of the global economy.
What started as a crisis in China is now a worldwide health emergency.
And companies are being hit in three key ways.
China is the world's workshop.
When its factories are closed, global business suffers.
The tech and auto sectors have been hit especially hard.
China accounts for 30 percent of global exports of electronic and electric components.
Coronavirus is also a serious challenge for consumer-facing businesses.
For luxury brands in particular...
...the disappearance of Chinese buyers is a potential disaster.
They account for as much as half of global sales.
Big brands rely heavily on consumers in China.
And Chinese tourists are heavy spenders on Fifth Avenue and the Champs-Elysees.
Analysts say a 10 percent drop in Chinese spending in the first half of this year...
...could hit annual profits by about 4 percent.
The outbreak has also grounded corporate travel for many companies.
Airlines had already cancelled flights, issued profit warnings,...
...and seen their share prices plunge even before coronavirus spread to Europe.
Now, some multinationals have suspended trips to countries where there has been an outbreak.